podemos decir muchas cosas malas de
Rusia Pero hay una fortaleza que nadie
les puede negar la energía habéis oído
bien si la regla de oro en cualquier
casino es que la banca siempre gana en
el juego de la energía Rusia siempre
gana al fin y al cabo es el país más
grande del Mundo con mucha diferencia
pero es que además su territorio está
repleto de recursos naturales lo que le
da una ventaja competitiva enorme pensad
sin ir más lejos en la cuarta Economía
del mundo en Alemania mucho Volkswagen
por aquí siemens por allá pero durante
décadas Alemania ha dependido del gas
ruso para tener energía barata y como
bien sabéis todo esto saltó por los
aires con la invasión rusa de Ucrania y
claro ha costado mucho encontrar
alternativas y ya sé lo que habréis
pensado muchos en más de una ocasión
Cómo reducir la dependencia rusa fácil
construyendo centrales nucleares
acabemos de una vez por todas con el
tabú que siempre ha rodeado a la energía
nuclear es una fuente de energía estable
limpia y sobre todo no depende de Rusia
Pues como ya decíamos al principio del
vídeo en el juego de la energía Rusia
siempre gana
atentos a este gráfico
Rusia tiene 37 reactores nucleares lo
que le convierte en el cuarto país del
mundo con más reactores pero no solo eso
las centrales nucleares también
necesitan combustible en este caso
hablamos de uranio enriquecido Pues bien
quién domina el mercado mundial del
uranio enriquecido Exacto Rusia y ya sé
lo que me diréis muchos pero cuántas
minas de uranio tiene Rusia pues no
muchas en realidad Rusia solo supone el
5% del uranio que se produce en todo el
planeta ahora bien el uranio que sale de
las minas vale para muy poco hay que
enriquecerlo y Quién es el líder
enriquecimiento de uranio la empresa
rusa rosatón para que os hagáis una idea
esta empresa supone el 46% de la
capacidad de enriquecimiento en todo el
mundo esto explica tal y como os contó
couto en visualpolitik el pasado febrero
por qué occidente no impone sanciones a
la corporación Estatal rusa de energía
atómica pero que no cunda el pánico
porque hay alternativas sí habéis oído
bien De igual forma que el gas natural
licuado permite que compremos gas a
otros proveedores que no son Rusia con
El combustible nuclear también hay otra
alternativa un país que puede enriquecer
uranio hablamos de Francia La pregunta
es de verdad Francia quiere sustituir a
Rusia en el liderazgo de este sector
pues lo cierto es que sí de hecho tienen
su estrategia para hacerlo el problema
Pues el principal problema es que el
sector nuclear francés lleva 15 años
viviendo en una crisis permanente cuando
apagan un fuego enseguida se le origina
a otro y el último ha sido en un lugar
tan alejado como inesperado golpe de
estado níger genera preocupaciones sobre
la dependencia del uranio de Francia y
la Unión Europea como sabéis níger era
la última democracia del sahell y uno de
los mayores productores de uranio del
mundo el presidente bazum era
considerado por Francia como un Aliado
importante para combatir el auge del
yihadismo en la región Sí pero también
para proveer de uranio al país ahora
todo indica que las cosas podrán cambiar
con la nueva junta militar de níger los
militares reprochan constantemente a
Francia sus abusos como antigua
metrópoli y la acusan de entrometerse en
sus asuntos internos acusación bastante
legítima todo se ha dicho así que la
pregunta es qué tiene que ver lo que
está pasando en níger con la estrategia
francesa de dominar el mercado de
combustible nuclear En qué consiste
exactamente esta estrategia va a seguir
occidente comprando ureano enriquecido
Rusia hoy en visualpolitik vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Aplausos]
el uranio de las colonias
[Música]
hace 50 años se produjo la famosa crisis
del petróleo allá por el año 1973 las
petromonarquías decidieron recortar su
producción de crudo de un día para otro
el precio del zumo de dinosaurios se
multiplicó por cuatro y la economía
mundial se tambaleó esto incluía por
supuesto a Francia casi toda su
electricidad venía de centrales
alimentadas por hidrocarburos por aquel
entonces solo el 5% de la energía
francesa venía de machacar átomos esta
crisis fue clave para que se activara el
plan mesmer hablamos de Pierre que era
el Primer Ministro de hoy del presidente
pompidou en 1934 presentó un plan para
que Francia dejara de depender del
petróleo extranjero ya sabéis que
Francia es un país muy poco amigo del
comercio internacional y siempre tienden
Al proteccionismo pero es que en estos
momentos la realidad parecía darles la
razón Y cómo podían dejar de depender
del zumo de dinosaurio fácil solución
centrales nucleares como si no hubiera
mañana solo necesitaban una cosa uranio
Y dónde podían encontrarlo pues la
comisión francesa para la energía
atómica ya sabía dónde podían
encontrarlo las
han sido dos de Las mayores del mundo
por eso cuando en 1960 este país
africano obtuvo su independencia París
se aseguró acceso prioritario los
recursos naturales de níger mediante un
tratado la explotación a gran escala de
estas minas de uranio arrancó entre
finales de los años 60 y la década de
los años 70 allí Francia pudo desplegar
todas las malas prácticas que ya había
estado experimentando en gabón
[Música]
Francia comenzó a operar en 1960 la mina
de uranio de munana en gabón a finales
de los 60 las mediciones registraron
altos niveles de radiación gama y Alfa
entre los trabajadores mineros adoptar
los protocolos de protección contra la
radiación utilizados en Francia requería
de costosas inversiones y los franceses
no estaban por la labor fue mucho más
rentable la solución adoptada triplicar
los umbrales a partir de los cuales la
exposición a la radiación se consideraba
peligrosa para la salud humana
Esta es una de las ventajas que tenían
las minas de las antiguas colonias para
Francia sus costes eran muchísimo más
reducidos porque a quién le importaba la
seguridad o el bienestar de los Mineros
de un país que ni se sabe dónde está en
el mapa y ya sé lo que algunos estaréis
pensando vale seguro que morirían muchos
mineros pero vamos a ser cínicos al
menos el país sacaría dinero por vender
sus recursos naturales no estamos
hablando de una Colonia francesa Y eso
significa que los acuerdos eran
abusivamente ventajosos para París para
que os hagáis una idea durante muchas
décadas las empresas mineras francesas
solo pagaron a níger el 5,5% de sus
ingresos en impuestos para que os hagáis
una idea en Canadá o en kazajistán donde
el actual orano que es la empresa
francesa atómica produce uranio desde
finales de los 90 las tasas de regalías
son del 13 o del 18,5% respectivamente
esto ha provocado disparidades como las
que podéis ver en este gráfico entre la
cantidad de uranio producido y los
ingresos que recibe el país A cambio en
el año 2014 se negoció un nuevo acuerdo
entre níger y la empresa orano que por
Entonces se había cambiado un nombre a
areba la tasa de regalías se elevó del
5,5% a una cifra en torno al 12% siempre
que se dieran ciertas condiciones de
rentabilidad y precio del uranio vamos
que es el mejor ligeramente las
condiciones para suavizar el expolio
pero Francia ha seguido jugando en níger
con ventaja respecto al mercado
internacional todo esto hay que sumarle
las pocas condiciones de seguridad de
los mineros si a esto le añadimos que
Niger es uno de los países más pobres
del mundo seguramente podremos hablar de
o más de la maldición de los recursos
naturales que como sabéis es un fenómeno
del que hemos estado hablando hasta la
saciedad tanto en visualpolitik como en
nuestro canal hermano visual economic Y
por supuesto Niger no ha sido la
excepción
en 1934 el teniente coronel seinik con
She dio un golpe de estado presidente
hasta 1987 con se reclamó recibir
directamente la producción de óxido de
uranio igual al porcentaje de
participación del estado de níger en las
filiales nigerinas de las empresas
mineras francesas un porcentaje superior
al 30%. con se quería vender el uranio
por su cuenta en el mercado
internacional y las intenciones atómicas
de sus clientes no eran precisamente
pacíficas hablamos del Irak de San José
y la liba de gadafi Pakistán de hecho se
le atribuye la frase venderemos uranio
incluso al si es necesario y
ahora ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
todos dado que la junta militar que ha
tomado el poder en níger tiene ganas de
revancha frente a Francia veremos cómo
se rompen los acuerdos de explotación de
sus Minas como expulsan ahora no del
país y como Francia pierde todo el
uranio de níger y claro teniendo en
cuenta que las centrales nucleares
generan en torno al 70% de la
electricidad de Francia si de repente
los militares de níger cortan el
suministro de uranio seguro que la
producción energética de Francia se
viene abajo verdad pues no porque a
diferencia de Alemania con el gas ruso
Francia sí ha hecho sus deberes y además
los ha hecho muy bien
Francia ha sabido diversificar su
suministro de uranio según los datos de
los últimos 10 años las
88.200 toneladas de uranio natural
importadas por Francia procedieron
principalmente de tres países kazajistán
con un 27% níger con un 20 y Uzbekistán
con un 19 también destacan las
importaciones de Australia y namibia con
un 14% en cada caso en cuanto a los
datos anuales el uranio de níger nunca
supuso más de un 35% de las
importaciones francesas en un mismo
ejercicio
[Música]
estos datos son muy similares a los de
orano en 2010 las minas de níger
proporcionaban dos tercios de su
producción mundial sin embargo una
década más tarde hoy en día Niger aporta
menos de un tercio después de que
cerraran en 2021 la mina de kominac y
todo esto quiere decir que el uranio de
níger antaño decisivo tiene ahora una
importancia relativa para el sistema
energético francés porque apenas supone
un 20% del uranio que importan comparada
eso con el 60% que suponía el gas ruso
para Alemania o incluso el 90% que
suponía para otros países como República
Checa En otras palabras que si Niger
corta el Grifo del uranio Francia podría
reemplazarlo fácilmente por
importaciones de otros países ahora bien
significa esto que Francia no tenga
problemas con lo que ocurre en níger
pues no para nada ahora bien el problema
con el uranio de este país viene por
otro lado por donde Pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
un mercado dominado por Rusia
al igual que las centrales de ciclo
combinado utilizan el gas natural como
combustible para generar electricidad
las centrales nucleares también
necesitan su propio combustible el
proceso más utilizado en las plantas
atómicas para generar energía es la
fisión nuclear y para ello necesitan un
elemento que sea visible y ahí es donde
entra en juego el uranio ahora bien
igual que el petróleo lo tienes que
refinar para obtener combustibles como
la gasolina o el gasóleo el uranio
también lo tienes que enriquecer para
utilizarlo como combustible las
centrales nucleares Y sí ya sé que esto
del uranio enriquecido suena a bomba
atómica porque es que es el mismo
proceso que el que se necesita para
fabricar bombas nucleares lo que cambia
es el nivel de enriquecimiento que se
necesita Mirad
el uranio natural tal como se extrae de
las minas está compuesto en un
99,3%, por isótopos de uranio 238 no
visibles la parte visible los isótopos
de uranio 235 sólo suponen el 0,7%.
enriquecido a entre un 3 y un 5%, este
uranio sirve como combustible nuclear
para las centrales que generan
electricidad hasta el 20%, el uranio
enriquecido sirve para producir isótopos
médicos utilizados especialmente en el
diagnóstico de algunos cánceres
finalmente para fabricar una bomba el
enriquecimiento debe llevarse hasta el
90%
y ahí está la clave que ha hecho que el
mercado Internacional del combustible
nuclear esté dominado por Rusia y diréis
Pero por qué Pues porque
tradicionalmente el uranio es
enriquecido a través de dos métodos
occidente se inclinó por el más sencillo
la difusión gaseosa sin embargo este
método es muy sencillo pero resulta
carísimo ya que requiere de muchísima
energía para enriquecer el uranio de
Cuánta energía estamos hablando pues la
planta de enriquecimiento que habría
Francia a finales de los años 70
consumía 15 teravatios por hora al año y
diréis eso es mucho es poco pues es la
misma cantidad de Electricidad que se
utilizaría actualmente para el alumbrado
público de París durante todo un siglo
habéis oído bien Un siglo
[Música]
durante las tres décadas que estuvo en
funcionamiento la planta de
enriquecimiento de uranio George best
fue el mayor consumidor de Electricidad
de Francia devoraba alrededor del 4% de
toda la producción eléctrica del país
galo de hecho en el apogeo de la Guerra
Fría alrededor del 7% de la generación
total de Electricidad de Estados Unidos
se dedicó al enriquecimiento de uranio
tanto para fines militares como civiles
sin embargo la difusión gaseosa era el
método utilizado por occidente ahora
bien que hacían Al otro lado del telón
de acero como sabéis la unión soviética
también tenía bombas y reactores
nucleares pero usaban una tecnología
mucho más compleja la de centrifugación
la ventaja de este sistema Pues que
consume 50 veces menos energía que el de
difusión gaseosa Y eso explica que
incluso a día de hoy en pleno año 2023
encontramos noticias como esta Putin
sigue vendiendo a Estados Unidos casi
mil millones de dólares en combustible
nuclear cuando cayó la unión soviética
en 1991 Estados Unidos y la nueva Rusia
acordaron lo que se conoce popularmente
como el programa de megatones a
megavatios hay que reconocer que el
nombre del programa era ocurrente
el uranio altamente enriquecido de las
antiguas ojivas nucleares soviéticas se
transformó en uranio poco enriquecido y
se envió a los Estados Unidos para
usarlo en Plantas civiles Asimismo las
eléctricas occidentales Se lanzaron a
adquirir una gran enriquecido ruso
beneficiándose de la tecnología más
competitiva de la época soviética y
llevando a la ruina a las instalaciones
de occidente que aún utilizaban el
método de difusión gaseosa conclusión
que En aquellos felices años 90 lo único
que corría peligro de acabarse con
borissin eran nuestras reservas de
alcohol Así que Rusia logró de esta
forma una posición de dominio de Mercado
que ha beneficiado enormemente a rosatón
que como sabéis es la corporación
Estatal rusa creada en 2007 por Vladimir
Putin para ser el gigante del mercado
global de la energía nuclear un gigante
absolutamente Intocable aún Incluso en
las condiciones más adversas aumenta la
presión sobre la Unión Europea para que
sancione a rosatón en el próximo paquete
de sanciones a Rusia ya lo tenéis ni
Bruselas ni Washington se han atrevido a
sancionar El combustible nuclear de
rosatón Es más hace años que Estados
Unidos dejó hacer uranio y
aproximadamente un tercio del
combustible nuclear que utiliza
actualmente se importa de Rusia que es
el mayor productor del mundo también es
el más barato y aún así la factura se
eleva cada año a casi mil millones de
dólares Así que en plena Guerra de
Ucrania con sanciones sobre el petróleo
sobre el gas natural y sobre miles de
empresas y productos de Rusia lo ideal
sería no depender del kremlin en cuenta
combustible nuclear verdad pues aquí es
donde entra en juego la estrategia de
Francia de qué estrategia hablamos pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
mi querida comunidad de visualpolitik si
estáis viendo Este vídeo desde Alemania
o desde España esto os va a sorprender
pero lo cierto Es que la energía nuclear
está de moda es más actualmente se están
construyendo en el mundo 59 reactores
nucleares y está previsto que estas
cifras aumenten en los próximos años en
111 además hay planes para otros 321
reactores el 40% de ellos se sitúan en
China pero otras potencias como Rusia o
la India también están apostando y muy
fuerte por la energía nuclear y esperad
un momento porque aquí en Europa también
hay países que no se quieren quedar
atrás Francia ya anunció antes de la
Guerra de Ucrania y construiría 6 nuevos
reactores pero es que también está Reino
Unido Polonia Países Bajos eslovenia
Eslovaquia República Checa Hungría
Bulgaria Rumanía lituania y es posible
que me haya dejado algún país y que
otros más se sumen después del
espaldarazo dado por la Unión Europea
esta tecnología atentos el parlamento de
la Unión Europea apoya a etiquetar las
inversiones En gas y energía nuclear
como verdes y es que veréis la
transición energética y la lucha contra
el cambio climático van a exigir y
muchas inversiones En nuevas tecnologías
y también en todo aquello que suponga
mantener nuestra calidad de vida al
mismo tiempo que reducimos las emisiones
de gases invernadero en este ámbito es
donde Bruselas ha decidido que la
renovables y la nuclear tienen que ir de
la mano y por estos motivos los países
europeos están dispuestos a darle una
nueva oportunidad a la energía atómica
dicho de otra forma que vamos a tener
más reactores nucleares y todo esto que
significa
[Música]
pues mucha más demanda de uranio
enriquecido es decir más producción de
minas y más producción para quien quiera
que lo pueda enriquecer y aquí es donde
entra Francia quieren aprovechar todo
este Renacimiento nuclear y ya están
trabajando en ello como refleja noticias
como esta Francia sopesa una nueva
planta de uranio para reducir la
dependencia de occidente de Rusia según
un portavoz de orano que es la compañía
Estatal francesa para energía atómica se
valoran dos opciones por un lado
construir una planta de enriquecimiento
de uranio en los Estados Unidos por el
otro otra opción que sería la más rápida
y probable que consiste en ampliar 50%
la capacidad de su moderna planta George
vssette 2 que está operativa de 2011 y
que ya enriquece uranio mediante la
técnica de la centrifugación para que os
hagáis una idea vamos a dar unas cifras
igual que el gas natural se mide en bcm
el huracán enriquecido se mide en swu es
decir unidades de trabajo separativo
Pues bien en su planta George v2 Francia
enriquece 7,5 millones de swe al año
aumentando un 50% podrían ampliar la
capacidad hasta 11 millones mientras que
las centrales nucleares francesas
necesitan actualmente alrededor de 6,5
millones de SW esto se corresponde con
las alrededor de 8000 toneladas de
uranio natural que Francia necesita para
sus centrales nucleares si piensa
producir 11 millones de SW necesitará
importar cada año más de 13.000
toneladas de uranio y aquí es donde
Niger podría generar un problema para
Francia
como os decía antes su sistema
energético puede permitirse el lujo de
prescindir de las casi 2.000 toneladas
que importa todos los años de nige
podría encontrar otros proveedores sin
problema pero es que Francia sí necesita
es uranio para su estrategia de
convertirse en un exportador importante
de combustible nuclear y en una
alternativa al dominio ruso en cualquier
caso que nadie dude que macron ya está
trabajando en esta dirección y eso
explica noticias como esta el uranio de
mongolia interesa a Francia habéis oído
bien macron y suministro de exteriores
han visitado mongolia en los últimos
meses y allí han mostrado interés en
realizar inversiones por valor de mil
millones de euros para hacerse con el
uranio de mongolia así como de otros
metales como el litio pero eso es un
proyectos a futuro por el momento
Francia tiene un dolor de cabeza muy
importante con níger y en general todo
accidente porque quién creéis que se
está haciendo fuerte en la región del
sahell Exacto Rusia y es probable que el
nuevo gobierno de níger sea mucho más
propenso a vender uranio barato a Rusia
antes que vender solo a Francia todo
esto significaría que Rusia seguiría
dominando el mercado del combustible
nuclear y todo esto significa que si el
mundo sigue por la energía nuclear todos
incluido occidente aumentaremos nuestra
dependencia de Rusia incrementando así
el poder de Putin y El poder del kremlin
pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que Francia tendrá éxito en su
estrategia o en el juego de la energía
siempre e inexorablemente gana Rusia
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribías a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]